now to a hard news story we are talking
chocolate Cadbury chocolate fans in the
US are up in arms it's a real business
story
the British streets will no longer be
available across the pond it is a win
for Hershey's but one Wall Street
Journal columnist it is a question of
Liberty Ralph Gardner jr. writes quote
as a full-blooded Patriot I believe the
United States is the greatest nation on
earth
only not when it comes to mass produced
chocolates this feels like a soviet-era
Iron Curtain falling over my freedom of
choice so essentially what's going on
here tom is that the chocolate the
Cadbury is making for the US market is
too similar to Hershey's and Hershey's
has been objecting to it and so now if
you're a can berries fan in the US
you're not going to be able to get your
chocolate you're reaching for the good
bring this over okay this is the truth
this is the tribute I brought back to my
Bloomberg team from Davos this cost me
like eight hundred and forty-two dollars
after this we're talking about right now
we're talking about we are talking about
high school it in the US and the mass
market is VIP listen it's not it's not
good in my in my humble are you really
does Alina I'm not only the case I don't
know I gonna reuse the case of the
segment listen the point is it's a
better product in England it has a
different taste it's the number one
ingredient on Cadbury's chocolate in
England is milk thank you
number one ingredients used I needed
keep going mr. Rhodes please perfect I
retreat are only eleven percent made of
cocoa whereas the Dairy Milk Cadbury
chocolate which I'm sure if you've
tasted you will acknowledge is a little
bit fuzzier that is because there is
more milk in it this is a terrible news
for stores like tea and sympathy which
is a chocolate store in the West Village
that specifically said they so say so
European chocolate yeah right
no but it's a really interesting story
about trade war okay like limps or those
the Swiss in the German company have
their stores on Fifth Avenue do they
have European chocolate of course I
don't know I'm asking yes well what do
you think toy sure is is your try one it
should I try one yeah let me go for the
this is oh this one has alcohol in it I
think this is like tequila only
one of us can eat you're gonna have to
read the prompter